Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Last
week or during the week,
we listened to
the verses that lead up to the middle
and longest verse of surah.
In this verse, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
gives us one description
of the hellfire
and he gives us a name
of one of the gates
or as some mention one of the levels. So
a gate to one of the levels of the
hellfire
which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala refers
to as
now this
name will come up again during this
surah
but Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
he says describing
the hellfire describing safar
he says
And so he tells us subhanahu waala that
is a reference to the hellfire.
A reference more specifically to one of
the gates of the hellfire.
Elsewhere Allah specifies in
that the hellfire has seven gates
and that the gates of the hellfire
has a designated group that will enter
through that particular gate to enter
their respective
place in the hellfire.
And the hellfire
is a place
that was described throughout the Quran
with many different descriptions.
You wouldn't open one chapter of the
Quran or one place in the Quran and find
all of the descriptions of the hellfire
there. Similarly, you wouldn't open a
chapter or a place in the Quran and find
all of the descriptions of paradise
there.
They are descriptions that have been
mentioned throughout the Quran from the
beginning to the end
for a number of reasons and for a great
wisdom.
But one of the most important reasons is
that each chapter of the Quran, so we
have 114 chapters. Each one of these
chapters
has a particular theme
and a particular climate to it. It has a
very particular tone to it. Some
chapters are more have a darker tone.
Some chapters have a lighter tone. Some
chapters have a more serious tone. Some
chapters have. And you will find through
each of these chapters, every single
verse, if you examine them close enough,
you'll find that there is a common
thread
that makes every verse and every
description and every point mentioned
in that chapter to be working towards
that common theme of the chapter.
The same thing goes with the stories of
the prophets. For instance, the story of
Maisam has been mentioned in many many
many dozens of chapters of the Quran.
However, each time it's mentioned, it's
from a different angle under a different
light. Different
details are mentioned. Other things
are left more vague. And the reason for
that is to match the general tone
of the chapter. The same thing goes with
the same detail, the same incident. So
for instance in surah, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala mentions the story of Ibraim
and his guests, his mysterious guests
that show up and they were angels, but
he didn't know they were angels at the
time. And they were sent to the people
of Sodom and Gomorrah to the people of L
to destroy that those twin towns
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
that
he prepared for them a meal
and in both chapters surah and surah
he mentions that that meal was aid.
meaning a calf, some cow meat, right?
Beef, however that was that he
slaughtered one of the heads of cattle
that he had for his guests.
However,
the same detail is not mentioned in both
places.
In
Allah says
that he made for them roasted
that that it was roasted in
that it was a very full and very fatty
animal. It wasn't lean meat that he
made for them. Why is this important and
why did it change? Right? They don't
contradict each other. to the contrary.
The general tone of surah and what a
person's subconscious picks up through
the verses of surah. Surah is a very
very terrifying
chapter of the Quran. As a matter of
fact, it is considered to be the chief
of most terrifying chapters of the
Quran.
And it is a cluster of chapters that is
referred to in the sunnah as
that these are a cluster or a group a
collection of chapters that the tone in
them is extremely terrifying and very
visually distressing.
They they are distressing to the to the
to the reader to the listener.
And so it is appropriate to mention the
heat and the roasting of even that meal.
So even that good thing and that meal
matches the tone of hoot. When we look
at
it is more important for the tone of the
chapter to mention the generosity of
Ibraim.
So, it's not he went and pecked out
the weakest going to die anyways of his
heads of cattle and slaughtered that for
his guests. Two birds with one stone.
No, he picked out the best that he had
for his guests because that chapter
deals withhed and the the effects
that has on the heart and the kinds of
actions that come from the people of
true Tohit. And so generosity is one of
those traits that is overwhelming for
the people of Tohit.
Here is no different. We find in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions one
aspect of the aspects of the hellfire
and that is that he says
he says that it neither leaves
nor lets. What does that mean? Meaning
it neither leaves the people in it to
live nor does it allow them to die. It
neither leaves the people in it to rest
nor does it allow them reprieve etc.
insert any terrifying
combination between those two. He says
subhanahu waala
that it will be brought out on the day
of judgment for everyone to see and that
specifically
meaning that it specializes in changing
the color of its inhabitants. Meaning
people that are in it, they are charred.
They are burnt. their skins are
constantly replenished and in
constant change due to the heat of the
hellfire. Now we go into another verse
which is a very interesting verse. It's
commonly misunderstood
and that is that Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala said
He tells us that the gatekeepers of the
hellfire are 19 in number.
When you say just the word 19 that,
anything could come to mind. And Abu
Jahil and Wii
and the other antagonists of the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam when
they heard these verses they started to
make fun of these verses and the
hellfire
and so Abu Jah took it upon himself and
said there's only 19 of them I could
take 19 on my own some of them said I'll
take half and you all take half and
we'll overthrow the the gatekeepers of
hell that doesn't sound so terrifying 19
why that specific number
and so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
sent down the verse
that these are not 19 human beings these
are angels they are the gatekeepers of
hell
and he mentions subhanahu wa ta'ala that
these are the chief gatekeepers of hell
19 in number under their command and is
employed an endless amount of angels
commissioned by Allah Suba
to specialize in
fitting and fashioning all aspects of
punishment
and curtailing these punishments for the
inhabitants of the hellfire. When a
person is entered into the hellfire, may
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala protect us. It
is not just a random place. It's not a
random place in the sense that you know
this bad place that many people
are thrown into and and no every single
person
will be punished based on his or her
actions
and exactly in a way that is fitting for
his or her life's legacy. Just like
paradise. Paradise is the exact
opposite.
Most of what we see of the descriptions
of hell, we can affirm their opposite in
paradise. And this is actually one of
the evidences, one of the types of
evidences that is used by the companions
in understanding
the descriptions of the hellfire and the
descriptions of paradise. Meaning that
when we find a description of paradise
of something, its exact opposite is true
for the hellfire. And when we find a
description of the hellfire, its exact
opposite is true for paradise.
And this is why there are the companions
Abbas and others extrapolate
that the hellfire
is a general name but it doesn't mean
that it's only fire that is in hell.
There is also extreme cold that is in
hell. There is extreme fire. There is
extremely cold drink, there is extremely
hot drink, etc. It is a place of
extremes and contrasts.
But the word enables
to the hellfire. And the hellfire is
shaped a cone.
and it has gates that are opened and
sealed
and it has varying degrees and varying
types of punishment.
So for instance the companions
understood
that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala when he says
in
he says
for
who are als
[Silence]
He says
that
in the hellfire there is and
boiling water that they will be forced
to drink and also extremely extremely
cold that they will be forced to drink.
And this contrast is what will what
will introduce such severe punishment to
the people of the hellfire.
However,
all of those descriptions, its opposite
is true for paradise. Its opposite is
true for paradise.
so for instance when Allah describes
paradise as as being a place that has no
cold in it nor does it have any extreme
cold nor extreme heat.
That means that the hellfire is a place
that has extreme cold and extreme heat
etc.
And this is actually a very interesting
topic
because when you look, you know, some
anthropologists
and some historians that study ancient
religions and more obscure religions,
you find that very ancient religions all
have a concept of a place of punishment
and a place of of bliss. this, but the
descriptions are very different. So, for
instance, in Alaska,
the ancient tribes that were there,
it said that they believed in a place
that was bitter cold and that was their
version of hell. It was extremely cold.
And so they say, see this is just the
figment of the human being's
imagination. No, it's not the figment of
the human being's imagination.
This is if this came from a revelation
of Allah
is an aspect of the hellfire that is
most befitting for the time and place.
So for instance, if if we all lived in a
really really cold place, bitter cold
all the time it's cold. It is always
freezing cold. What is the thing that we
are most sensitive to at that point?
Cold. And so what would scare us the
most? Descriptions of a place where you
will be eternally cold and you can never
get warm again. That would scare us most
thoroughly
if you were to tell us and we lived in a
frozen tundra of a place and you told
us, "Oh, there's a place called hellfire
and it's so hot." Well, for us that
doesn't sound so bad if we live in a
place that is always freezing cold.
Likewise, the Quran was revealed to a
people in one of the hottest deserts on
earth. It was extremely hot. And so
mentions of extreme cold as a punishment
are not so extreme to people in those
environments.
A place of ice and a place of cold, they
can't relate to that. That sounds rather
soothing. It doesn't really sound very
terrifying. And so each people are given
a description of the hellfire, a
description of paradise that is most
influential to them and most appropriate
for their culture.
some people will ask a question
about for instance paradise. Some of the
descriptions of paradise in it are
rivers of wine and rivers of milk and
rivers of honey. Person will say well I
don't honey. How is that good for
me? This is just an example.
This is just an example of what is in
paradise. No matter what is described to
us of paradise, it is impossible for you
and I to ever conjure up an image vivid
enough to adequately
imagine paradise.
Inah Muslim
Abu
narrates that the prophet Sam
said that Allahawel
himself has says has said
He says, "Allah himself has said, I have
prepared for my righteous servants
a place that is so blissful and
pleasureful
that no eye has never ever seen the
likes of, no ear has ever heard the
likes of, nor has it ever been imagined
by any human being. This statement here,
it has never been imagined by any human
being. Even if you read the Quran,
even if you imagine it and you have the
most vivid of imaginations,
this is all a mere parable, an example
of what paradise is. Paradise is a place
that only when you enter it will you
truly be able to come to grips with its
bliss and beauty. And likewise can be
said for the hellfire.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said
[Silence]
The prophet
wasallam said if the believer had any
idea of the true reality of the
hellfire,
no one would ever find it in himself to
ever disobey Allah again.
And if the disbeliever
ever
knew
of the reality of the paradise that
Allah has prepared for his believing
servants,
he would not find it in himself to ever
despair of the mercy of Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala again.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.